[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm Rhett come
on man don't seem so why is it I'm
saying I sound like you don't want to be
here I want to be here I'm just I'm just
got nervous you're nervous I'm just yeah
I just you're anxious I ain't about so
many thought process so much information
well that sounds like you're overwhelmed
welcome to your biscuits I'm Rhett you
know it came out it's welcome to your
biscuits I'm Rhett no you sound more
United
so I am excited are you frustrated yeah
I with your with the Ameri s I think
that there's so many thoughts in your
brain that I think you're yeah you're
overwhelmed with the process has led to
this conversation and I'm linked this
week at the roundtables of dim lighting
right we are continuing to the
discussion from a number of weeks back
surrounding the question do youtubers
watch YouTube and in part one this is
part two we said I hate to break it to
us and anyone else who might be
disappointed but no we don't really
watch YouTube as a form of entertainment
and that just feels wrong it feels wrong
ironic ironic surprising that there's a
shame there's a shame associated with it
shameful so that the question the more
operative question for part two for me
at least is is there anything worth
watching on YouTube for me I'm not
saying necessarily for you or for you
right but for me and we asked you guys
to suggest things that you thought would
resonate with us that are on the YouTube
platform and then we started wrestling
with the suggestions I actually started
wrestling with a lot of things about you
know we don't typically give assignments
to ourself that then requires a time
commitment
so I started wrestling with that like
when am I gonna start watching you if I
don't watch youtube videos
I'm such a schedule oriented person and
so focused like what am I gonna get to
it that's one thing I came up with and
I'll come back to the other things but
I'm curious well I can speak to I know
you watched you a lot more than I did
watch stuff and I got lots of stuff that
exact same thing so so let's start I
start there just with overarching X to
put things into perspective in terms of
how much visual entertainment I already
have in my life I think I realized over
the past few weeks that it actually
isn't that much time right what my life
has become when it turned in terms of
television and I'm using television in
the broad sense of stuff that you can
see that moves on a screen screen
tainment your screen tainment okay it
really comes down to my wife and I
making a decision to watch a series that
we're into before we go to bed and that
happens a minority of nights and in fact
this week we're recording this on a
Thursday and I have been spending most
of my in some work time as well kind of
checking out all this all these
suggestions
we'll get into exactly how much I've
enjoyed of each one or how far I went
but I only watched about 12 minutes of
one episode of Ozark because that's
something that Jesse and I've been
watching on Netflix really like the show
because I fell asleep 12 minutes in to
Joe's arc and I actually loved the show
and I still fell asleep did she keep
watching or did she was like you want me
to cut this off cuz she looked over and
look you know my eyes were beginning to
close yeah but that's actually not an
unusual weakness if we've got a lot of
stuff going on to not be able to
actually have time to sit down and watch
anything so we're kind of constantly
checking in with things like we talked
about in part one just for like research
purposes see what friends are up to
and see what people are saying about the
stuff that we're creating but there just
wasn't a lot of time so it was a huge
struggle for me to actually be able to
digest the suggestions that were sent in
I mean it was very very difficult yeah
we as I don't I just don't have
time to watch stuff we have structured
our entertainment lives our screen times
to not include YouTube so I I wasn't
willing to sacrifice the the shows that
Christian are watching like we're way
behind but watching Game of Thrones and
haven't I haven't even started watch
that Ozark show you got to get to it and
you know I'm committed I liked it I like
to just do one thing at once I don't
read multiple books at once you've got
all types of problems for a long time
yeah so I
there's no I just I couldn't find a lot
of time to watch things and I think that
is part of the issue is well when is
there I think the first question was is
there something that I can watch that
you guys can recommend that will take
the place of that thing that Chrissy and
I are gonna watch before we go to sleep
and it was that's a I mean that's a very
narrow in a lofty I feel like that's an
unrealistic reproach to bring to YouTube
because that's something that our wives
would agree on so I write I'm stepping
back from that and saying I don't watch
anything that we don't watch together if
you're right if I had more time on my
hands to watch things for entertainment
purposes like list let's say my wife was
out of town and I was making personal
individual decisions about what I was
gonna watch like for instance when my
vasectomy was was healing itself yeah
that was like that was like three days
of just binge watching right stuff and
again it was all television I mean I
bench watched a bunch of Netflix series
in movies during that during that time
that recovery time but if I were to do
that now the question is after the
research that I've done dipping my toes
into all these different new series and
shows and channels would I supplement
like if I get a second vasectomy because
you got two balls I mean you can get
another one
is that how it works no that's not how
it works if I get my vasectomy undone so
I can procreate
once again and there is a recovery time
would I then incorporate these
suggestions into the binge-watching
that's the question for me it's not
about what I'm gonna watch with my wife
because that's too narrow yeah I
actually think that I've learned some
things and I'm gonna make some
alterations because I feel like I was
thinking that neck was too big I've been
I've been missing I've been I've been
missing some things some things that I
need in my life and and I have found
those things
thanks to your recommendations Wow and
you didn't watch nearly as much as I did
but now feel like you well I I read
descriptions and I like though you read
descriptions I called and well no in
order to to prioritize what I felt would
resonate with me okay what quit so yeah
I mean I'm nervous saying that but I
think it's like saying I'll get back on
Instagram one day well I want to say a
few things not about specific will will
save beginning to talk about specific
shows for in a second just cover all the
bases here a few things that are true
about the process you guys suggested a
lot of things obviously we did not watch
everything you suggested just because we
didn't have time but if more than a
couple of people said something about it
we took we looked at it that was sort of
the criteria that we followed and then
how far did I go
I watched enough to get the idea but I
did not let's say if somebody had 30
minute videos on their channel because
that was the case with a number of
people yeah
I did not sit down and watch one whole
episode of anything because I just was
like I'm gonna shortchange somebody so I
would kind of scrub through get the idea
get the feel of the personality get the
feel of the style of the editing look at
the frequency of uploads get the basic
idea and I think I can draw a pretty
good conclusion but I don't think this
is a definitive conclusion as someone
who's experienced the channel on a
long-term basis so just that's one
caveat another thing I want to say is
we don't these are not necessarily
endorsements of the people behind the
channel we live in a problematic time
with problematic people and sometimes
you can say you should check out this
video and then you find out that this
person is already known to be
problematic in some way so I just want
to say that we have not done extensive
research is this very much just you
suggested something we looked at a few
of their videos and came to a conclusion
about their content so this is not an
endorsement of anybody personally in
anything they have done or haven't done
oh I'm glad you said that because okay
cuz I know how y'all guys are it's 2018
I know I've been around in 2018 since
the beginning of 2018
man you were here for it this is the top
I've been here since January 1 2018
so yeah
so and also just because we talked about
it doesn't mean that I think you should
watch it but the majority of the things
that I'm gonna talk about are things
that I have something to say about them
go ahead that makes sense doesn't it um
they made me think about something can I
can I just jump into the and tell you
the first thing that I decided to watch
when I looked at the initial list that
we made yeah it was the abandoned malls
so where is that defunct land no I got
it I got it on my my laptop list here
but it's I got a scare walls yes here it
is right here channel called this is Dan
Bell oh yeah hmm I'm familiar because
I'm like dead malls man I like the idea
that channel says informative tours of
some of the most depressed shopping
malls in the mid-atlantic region and
beyond so I started watching one of
these everyone this is Dan Bell and this
is my video tour of the Crystal River
mall located in Crystal River Florida
and the Warren mall located in Warren
Pennsylvania Kansas City wants to know
can i really eat this much food ice
cream ice cream ice cream it was like a
weird exercise in editing
voiceover driven and I could tell there
was some clips from the inside of a mall
but then it very quickly included these
two women like VHS seeming footage from
the 80s of these two women I think they
were beauty pageant contestants it was
like footage of them talking like so
this was like found footage okay and
then it was them it was she was doing an
interview about being on the on the
slopes and uh what's that place called
and not in Utah but in Colorado Aspen
that's it my brain is not working too
well today been watching too many
YouTube videos lately I'm afraid you're
in trouble
skiing in Aspen and like she's talking
about in any cut in footage of this
seemingly the same woman like tumbling
down the slopes and it was just and the
music was very retro a lot of great
editing choices
I love comedic and odd editing so I'm
like oh this can be this can be good it
was like medium paced and then it
started it was just weird you know
medium pace and then it started to
settle into tripod footage of slow pans
of malls that are open for business but
pretty much but nobody's there and he's
and then he's got a he's added a layer
of voiceover we he's given commentary on
when the JCPenney first came to this
mall and it's it's gonna leave at the
end of the year so if the Dick's
Sporting Goods doesn't come in they're
really in trouble and it's very dry
oh I wash plenty oh you watched it yeah
and I was like I'm just yeah I know you
didn't watch much I'm letting you talk
about this so Mr Dan Bell I got it I got
to give it to you if that even whether
that's your real name or not I think
you're I think you're brilliant
your Sensibility comedic ly and
creatively and otherwise I'm loving you
I just don't and I really enjoyed it and
I
I just don't know where that fits into I
just don't have a place in my life to to
keep going back to that I wish I did
that is the operative question because I
I got so much joy from the fact that
somebody had this idea and then went
with it not just for one video that was
just a few minutes but a video that was
I mean it could have I think it was a 15
minute it could've been a 20 minute
video some of them are very long yeah
and then he did he did he does a lot of
them well and he doesn't just have that
he has another series where he to other
guys he may be with him but I think I
think it's just two other guys go to
these dirty hotels and do basically I
looked at the janitors of really nasty
hotel they had a black light blue eyes I
saw the trailer for that and it was like
stuff that they find using a black light
now I was like ah not this was not as
much for me okay well I want to tell you
what I think about that and then a lot
of things that are very much like that
you know I think it fits in in a second
first we do want to let you know that
you can grab this mythicality that I am
wearing this is which one is this the
connectivity we're so excited about so
excited these three t-shirts the
mythicality 's yeah it might already be
sold out hope it's not so moving very
quickly and I don't think we're gonna be
making any more I mean we don't know
yeah why would we know so like we're in
charge we're just we're excited about
bringing you guys new designs as opposed
to just getting into something and just
producing it forever so we're
experimenting with new things it's more
likely than not that when we come out
with new things that it unless it's like
a mug that says good mythical morning on
it it's gonna come out it's gonna be
cool and then it's gonna be gone so
these are cool right now they may
already be gone I don't know but I got
one good one
got a mythical dot store support
internat Ament express yourself have fun
on your body with clothes that's one on
your buddy have fun on your body with
your clothes on can you
are you gonna tell me something you
watch because I'm curious what's the
first thing you went to well this
spreadsheet is no longer organized in
the way that it was but Dan Bell was one
of the first one it intrigued you as
well I did I took a peek at every single
thing on the let made it into our
spreadsheet and I remember coming to the
conclusion that this is Dan Bell Dan
Bell has an incredible sense of humor
this is something that is very
interesting to me and but then I always
asked the question and this is the
question that I'm gonna ask about all of
this is am i compelled to watch this if
I got home tonight and my wife was like
I'm gonna go hang with my friends and I
had just unstructured personal creative
time would I choose to go to his channel
for non-research purposes and I don't
and I think that the court has nothing
to do with hit the content because the
content is great it just has to do with
the fact that I am more drawn to these
things that fit a certain set of
criteria which I actually I tweeted this
to get I wanted to make sure that I left
no stone unturned a lot of people
criticize the tweet because they were
like you're setting up a criteria that
doesn't apply to YouTube videos and I
did that on purpose because I put the
criteria on the stuff that I was looking
for that applied to the stuff that I was
already watching to make sure that
YouTube wasn't producing something that
already fit the criteria of the stuff
that I watch every night so I switch is
please give me your wrecks of YouTube
content that fits the following criteria
number one is scripted / narrative which
I learned that a lot of people do not
know what those words mean number two
it's not on YouTube premium because I
was already familiar with everything on
YouTube premium three it's not a
standalone video because there's lots of
scripted sketches but rather a story
across multiple videos and for its
regularly and currently being updated or
scheduled because I wanted it to be
something that I could point people to
in their beast it's something new to
expect like I can anticipate the next
season of a show and I am gonna go
through some of the stuff that people
suggested first of all people suggested
stuff lots of people suggested stuff
that was unscripted documentary series
reality series that kind of thing which
that's fair game for the overall
exercise but you were trying to narrow
it down
I was specific a video but
because of the other stuff that you
we've already looked at yes so hit me
with something man
okay watch I'm gonna go on to one that
fascinated me that I did I'm calling
this the niche interest category so
let's stay in that aunts Canada gather
round
AC family and let's learn about the
amazing ways of ant colony fusion and
ant war okay this is a dude I guess he's
in Canada maybe just the answer in
Canada but I assume they're in the same
place he has colonies multiple colonies
of ants
and he plays God with ants what do you
mean by that
meaning say for instance he has a fire
ant colony that he calls the fire nation
and he has cameras in there filming what
they're doing and then he floods the
nest with water and does a voiceover he
basically gets all this footage of him
flooding the the nest with water and
then trying to figure out how are the
ants going to respond so it is like a
story right and then he does this voice
over and shows you all the footage
together and shows you how the ants
responded and I have to say that it was
captivating fascinating mesmerizing what
well done well edited yeah I mean it was
not done to the degree that it would be
done if he had like really high dollar
like nature photography cameras that
were like up inside the colony and stuff
like that it still feels like it's a
dude with the camera but it's but he's
getting very close to these ants I mean
yeah I didn't find myself being
frustrated with the footage if that's
what you're getting at yeah the in it
was pretty slow paced we're talking on
like 20 minutes to tell the story of
ants but it's regularly updated lots of
people watch it that fire ant nation
thing had over 2 million views I think
if I'm recalling correctly in it it old
they survive you'll have to watch it
fine I'm not gonna do a spoiler but that
the wood that you talked about Dan Bell
and then ants Canada and then there's a
bunch of other ones that's throwing
that we can go into in a second it I
just was like this could only exist on
YouTube
YouTube has created a platform for a
dude to collect ants and tell stories
about them on his own terms and on the
ants own terms for a very interested
audience in a very faithful audience and
a c-fam I think he calls them ants
Canada fam okay and I was like that
right there is a beautiful thing not
that I
I knew this existed I knew that these
niche interests very very niche
interests communities existed but to see
it in action and actually sit down and
enjoy it was like a lot of light bulbs
went off I was like well of course this
is what I'm finding something that could
not and should not exist in any sort of
traditional place it is a YouTube thing
exclusively but you but you don't you
don't see yourself going back there no
ice all I needed to see that's the thing
and I enjoyed it but do I care about
what happens with the fire hands next
week
no I don't lots of people do though ac
fams gonna be okay
you know what I'm saying but Rhett's not
gonna be a part of AC fam and I feel
like I should be ashamed of that but I'm
just being honest there's another
channel is it not called human I mean
does he own youtube.com slash human like
I think there's no way that's just the
nicest way no this is what he called I
don't know what the actual URL is and
see this is one that I should okay this
is no magic description woodcutting
videos by a guy who loves wood cutting
and so I clicked on this and first of
all there's other videos on his channel
it's not highly formatted but it's a guy
who climbs trees and chop chop each
prunes and trims and cuts down trees or
limbs off of trees as an employee of a
company which he does not appear to own
or being charged he's just a guy with a
chainsaw who works amongst a team of
people or we're getting him in trouble
I don't know I don't know how you know
how much permission he has he's like in
people's backyards he's very well-known
up climbing he's got a GoPro on the
first-person perspective and then and
then like a ground perspective of what
he's doing he puts the videos up side by
side so he's cutting this limb down and
then you see from the street view at the
limb falling down from the tree but
there's a lifestyle blog element like
there were clips in the one video that I
watched of him he's like with the other
team members and he's like it's raining
today you guys excited we're gonna get
out there we're gonna do this and like
he got a you got a response from one of
his a guy that he works with and then
he's off he's like alright come take a
look we're going into the backyard this
is the tree and then you know he some of
them get millions of views because what
happened because things happen like
something went wrong and even saying I
don't run yeah they get more views yeah
now okay so you money Dottie but but
that was a is a lifestyle vlog of a guy
cutting tree limb and I'm a wood lover
right you know that I've made it very
clear I watched a couple of these videos
I was like this is very well done this
is the best way I could think to
approach cutting down trees and filming
it and putting it on YouTube yeah you
have no notes no notes and then I was
like but am I gonna come back and watch
more of these even if it got more
personal I don't think I would come back
I can tell you're not coming back I
don't think I'm coming back I mean I I
think about like I think of daily
vloggers who I never watched but you
know from the from everything that
happens in their lives you feel like you
know them and you're understand feeling
like you're a part of somebody's life
have you ever feel you ever followed
somebody like that I know I've never
followed somebody like that which is
again this is another aspect that this
is sort of like a macro conclusion that
we would eventually get to well go ahead
and say it now
YouTube is incredibly personality driven
it's not format driven first its
personality driven first
even though we are talking about very
niche things you're still kind of
understanding and exploring these niche
things through the personality of
someone who is kind of in charge of the
whole thing and is letting you into
their life and that's super appealing
and I think that's even with what we do
you don't you probably got into what we
do based on one thing you saw it might
have been way back in the day with a
music video it might have been an
episode of GMM it may have been this
podcast it may have been something else
we did like commercial kings or buddy
system but chances are you stuck around
not just because you'd liked what we did
because you'd liked us in some way and
that is an incredible thing that is very
specific to youtube and then I just
started thinking do I just not like
people what's wrong with me like I do I
can't commit to any person to the level
that I would say I actually want to know
what's happening in their life every
single day and I want to keep going back
like it's just not something and I think
it maybe it's just a generational thing
that I like missed some boat some young
boat I I made a young boat it's
obviously valuable and compelling you
know because even when it's something
that I'm interested in genuinely but you
know well that guy was just he I you
didn't I didn't get the impression that
in between him cutting down limbs you
also started to learn about stakes in
his in his private life but if I
actually his wife's pregnant or
something if I was cutting down trees on
a daily basis and like needed pointers
and people to compare with I might keep
going back for a functional standpoint
and then maybe I would get into the
personality now let me I want just we
can move to another category because I
want to keep moving just a few other
things we found in this niche interest
just because it's just entertaining
defunct land the thing I mentioned this
is basically history of extinct extinct
theme parks and other like themed
entertainment experiences like there's
an episode about the Nickelodeon Hotel
then there's one called Steve 1989 M REM
fo that's the name for the channel and
this guy I wish it we shouted him out of
achievement
just as MRE taste-test even will
even more niche there's a there's a
channel called the Great War that tells
the story of World War one as it
unfolded week by week 100 years ago
today on July 28 1914 the Empire of
austria-hungary declared war on the
kingdom of Serbia so literally when they
started this series they were like it's
week one in World War one here's what
happened in week 1 and then every week
they update it and you're following
along with the world war and it's this
like incredibly detailed hosted by one
guy as far as I could see with the ones
I watched like history buff video that I
was mesmerised by but I was kind of
mesmerized by the concept but I didn't
think I was like you know I'm not
interested in following the world war
week by week so but you know what lots
of people are well I and I haven't
watched Ken Burns documentaries I
watched some of them but you know I
don't find myself continuing to go back
a lot yeah something even more in-depth
I get it but it's not for me I'm I'm I'm
absolutely amazed by it and I understand
why it exists and maybe there is
something that I've yet to find that I
will be like I mean I you know I like to
eat beans I'm all about beans but could
you really have a channel about beans
and if you did would I continue watching
it you know I love eating beans but I
can't eat the beans I see on the screen
that rhymes like dr. Seuss all of a
sudden yeah yeah you can make that show
but you wouldn't watch that show that's
the problem isn't it I wouldn't watch it
you can watch it I feel guilty oh
another thing I want to say speaking of
feeling guilty we're not telling who
shot who who recommended these things
just because multiple people did and so
that we would just forever be
mispronouncing user names so thank you
for everybody participated sorry we're
not calling you out for recommending
these okay let's move on to what I'm
calling the TV category because I think
this is an interesting thing in fact
that there are shows on YouTube that are
essentially replicating something that
would exist on television so we just
talked about something that would only
exist on YouTube
that's based on a niche interest that
we're saying
while it's great we would not go back to
them we haven't found that thing yet but
then there's the things that you could
find elsewhere but there are YouTube
versions of them brave wilderness the
coyote Peterson from what I've been told
gets maimed bitten chewed up spit out
any other uncomfortable verb with them
with amazing with an amazing ability to
talk his way through it
I would definitely sit down with my kids
like Lincoln
I'm sure Lando would love it I haven't
done it I know Lincoln's watched a few
clips on his own but if there's if if
we're having some family hangout time
it's like hey let's watch some some
videos let's watch some brave wilderness
videos like absolutely we could do that
it's like the mean we a modern-day Steve
Irwin
yeah with I mean we we sat down and
watch that Bear Grylls show let's watch
let's watch coyote Peterson absolutely
and you might say that he actually has
innovated on the platform because of the
way he's like letting himself get bit by
things is something that is not what
hasn't been part of you know traditional
you know what kind of TV would you
nature TV mm-hmm so he's kind of he's
putting himself in the situation putting
himself in harm's way in a way that
hasn't been done before incredibly well
done in a Steve area Steve Irwin way
incredibly well done he's very engaging
and I'd what if I see like if I see one
of his videos trending and it's like oh
that's something that's crazy I will
watch it and be entertained by it but
again does it pass the test of if I'm
home alone I make the choice to watch it
not yet it doesn't now yeah it's it's
great but but that's but that is going
on my family list okay like I I'm making
that decision so that's one of them
minefield
lots of people talked about that this is
this is the YouTube premium series my
michael stevens vsauce imagine being
confined to a 10 by 10 foot room in
complete isolation i
be staying in this room for three days
this again this is something that is
very well done but there's other series
on Netflix Amazon traditional television
science channel that kind of check a lot
of the same boxes I have a personal
connection to Michael because he's been
on the show and I think he's set right
here at this table yep and I like him a
lot and so I'm more invested in it when
watching it because I'm oh there's a guy
that I know who's hosting it well I was
staying at my brother and sister-in-laws
house and JB said he had watched a few
am I like oh yeah I want to watch some
of these and we binge dois CH like we
had a few hours and we were just
watching him and it's it's great I mean
I would watch I would watch those with
the kids too because there's there's
lots of stuff to learn and they're done
in a very smart way and he's very he
just it's very immersive so it's it's
very well done some are some are better
than others depending on the the topic
but that's true of any any one of those
yeah any any one of those shows but
again I highly recommend that and if I
hadn't been watch that that would also
be on like in in the family viewing hey
we got we got an hour
we don't have we're not gonna sit down
and watch a movie but we're gonna sit we
could sit down and watch something
together I actually think you can
improve our family time if I started
making a list of those things because we
just find ourselves like going into our
own rooms because Lilly wants to watch
the office by herself and I or Lincoln
wants to be on his phone to play video
games it'd be a way to bring us together
yeah so that's on my list I would say
BuzzFeed unsolved this week I'm buzzed
feeling solved we discuss what may be
the oldest mystery in the United States
a lot of people talked about this and I
did watch a couple of episodes and I was
interested in it and and to the same
degree that I would be interested if I
was in a certain mood while sort of
flipping through Netflix suggestions and
I saw some weird unsolved mysteries type
show but typically the way that I would
do that is if I was kind of trying to
like
a little time before like we watched a
movie or we watched a scripted series
and I had a little time and I was like I
got 20 minutes I'll check out this thing
about this conspiracy and I would sit
there and watch it and to me it checks
the exact same box I don't think that
it's any better or worse than something
again I haven't know anything to compare
it to my guess I'll compare it to
something loosely is dark tourist which
is guy from New Zealand hosting a show
on Netflix where it's the dock you
follow series he watches but he goes to
like creepy / dark places that you can
you know you can buy ticket to basically
that are really weird
very well done show I highly recommend
it if you're in the dark tourism stuff
but again I was I just had an hour I was
sitting on the couch and a couple of
kids were in there I was like I'll find
something I'm gonna go to Netflix and
then I'm gonna find something so I
wasn't browsing on YouTube because I
didn't have any hope that there would be
anything that could like we could have a
shared experience for an hour right you
know so I might add that one to the list
I'm not as interested in it
Britain my cousin he's like super into
ghosts and unsolved mystery type stuff
and he loves that show those of you that
saw yeah he told me that okay but again
there's not a there's an yeah I think
well I got an hour I'm gonna go on
Netflix that it's not I got an hour I'm
gonna go on YouTube it's it it's still
appointment viewing and I think that's
that that's what really the question is
is what on YouTube is gonna become a
part of my appointment viewing well I'm
gonna get to some stuff that I think
does pass that to pass the test for me
but I'm not there yet this is sort of an
outlier that just fascinated me a guy
named Brian Jordan Alvarez who is an
actor that I have seen in things he's
been in a bunch of things so when you
see his face you're like oh yeah I know
that guy and he's doing a really really
fascinating thing with his YouTube
channel
he's basically ants nope no ants
it's not even in Canada as far as I can
tell based on the landscape it looks
like Los Angeles mostly he is doing
traditionally traditional scripted
content but he's putting it directly on
YouTube so a lot of people mentions he
does sketches he just standalone
sketches but a lot of people do skits
analyst catches his sketches are
actually funny which is oh very
difficult to find on YouTube in my
opinion but what I will say that he's
doing he's doing that it's even more
interesting he has a series that I think
he's in a couple of seasons of called
the gay and wondrous life of Kaleb Gallo
okay and this is a character it's a
character that he plays and then he's
got another actor a woman that is in a
lot of the things with him they're kind
of like a comedy duo together they're in
a bunch of the videos together say like
hey girl and like I don't get baseball
like my car's broken and I don't know
how to change the tire she's also
unestablished
actress it's like if you go to their
IMDb's for both of these people you see
oh they're very busy they're working
actors but they still put all this
creative effort into the series like
this is a this is a webseries that okay
it doesn't have it obviously doesn't
have the budget of something that's on a
traditional network or even something so
on YouTube premium but you kind of very
quickly sort of forget about that as
soon as you start watching it so it kind
of has a little bit of a web series feel
to it but it's just well acted
well-written and he's a compelling
character she's a compelling character I
mean there's probably other stuff like
this out there but you guys recommended
it so I checked it out and then the
thing that kind of blew me away was the
fact that just recently he posted an
entire movie a feature-length movie
called grandmother's gold which is like
an hour and 20 minute film that I mean
they put a lot into this now it probably
submitted to film festivals I don't know
what else happen with it but at some
point he decided I'm just gonna put it
on YouTube so just very interesting that
he's doing anything you as we're talking
about that film there's maybe a couple
hundred thousand it's like been up for a
few
weeks okay which is I mean which is
impressive for something that long and
then a lot of the series itself I think
the caleb gallo series had gets hundreds
of thousands of views maybe even a
million on an episode or two so there's
a lot of people watching this but he's
doing something incredibly ambitious
that's very it's notable because we know
how difficult it is to create scripted
content and we basically just made the
decision that we're not going to do it
unless we get the kind of budgets that
we can get from somebody like YouTube
premium because it's just too hard right
but he's so what are you gonna are you
are you guys you're gonna start watching
this channel I know that if basically
the way I feel about his channel right
now and this applies to the sketches too
it's just like okay if I am like I want
to laugh right now I specifically want
to laugh and I and I I know I can go to
this channel and get a laugh am I gonna
sit down and watch that entire movie
maybe but am I gonna watch it as opposed
to watching the oscar-nominated movies
that I haven't gotten around to watching
yet if I do it's gonna be because I'm
impressed by the gumption that this guy
has to go out and make a film mm-hmm but
I'm not but if I'm not if I haven't yet
seen an oscar-nominated film or
something that somebody is recommending
or something that's you know popping up
on Rotten Tomatoes is highly ranked I'm
probably gonna go to those features
before I go to this self-financed thing
that's gonna end up probably ultimately
if I compare them apples to apples is
not going to be as good okay but I'm
super impressed
let me just him super impressed guy and
I have no doubt that he's gonna end up
doing something that you'll know that
name get to something that you're not
only impressed by it but it's gonna
impact your habits well this is another
outlier and this already has impacted my
habits okay is what Ethan and ela are
doing with their podcast we're
discussing like all the taboo we're back
north and I don't sixty minutes really
where their channel h3h3 productions I
mean I we said it when we were on their
podcast
that there's some of the most genuinely
funny people on YouTube it's just like
effortlessly funny not trying too hard
just it just happens and everything
Ethan says is just funny to me and then
what he decided to do with the HTTP
podcast I think of his podcast in the
way that I think about you know like Joe
Rogan if Joe Rogan's got somebody on
that I'm interested in then I'm
interested in the way that he's going to
talk but that's a podcast isn't that's
not what we're talking about here it's
YouTube content that's all I'm saying
and so I'm saying that it's an outlier
that I wanted to acknowledge but if
you're gonna listen to it you're gonna
listen to it through a podcasting app
you're not gonna watch the video
what do you yeah I probably would enjoy
the way I do most of my podcasters which
is by ear right so you're making me take
that one out okay I'm just I'm just
trying to be helpful okay all right I I
feel like I found some things that are
changing the game and I feel like I can
commit feel like I can commit give it to
me so what I've been waiting for okay
all right I got a I got a couple too but
there there's oh they're gonna be
different than yours and there's other
examples of these and these both of
these guys have been around for a while
but I had never really dug into the
degree that I did and I'm calling these
the category mock vlog okay so this is
people making what looks to be Internet
content that would typically be
unscripted lifestyle stuff but then when
you dig in you realize that it's all
scripted and actually that's what makes
it funny or it's loosely scripted sugar
pine seven okay so these guys one show
of the year right they be the last show
of the year last year yeah it probably
happened again this year someone will
beat us we're always nominated never
winning always a bride always a
bridesmaid never a bride that's what we
are but so these guys are doing
something the guy who kind of started
the thing what an a multiple a couple of
the guys were on the North Face where
employees at SourceFed and the
very first vlog is SourceFed is over as
ended and he does this it's kind of a
log meets Arrested Development meets
Curb Your Enthusiasm he's basically he's
got a camera he's filming his friends
who everybody everybody's funny all the
personalities are funny they're doing
absolutely ridiculous things that are
obviously set up and obviously planned
and scripted but they're all improving
and then he is offering his vo
commentary in perfectly buoyant water
that is body temperature I could tell
Kip lost track of what I was saying he
was looking at the cars and it's this
hybrid thing that doesn't exist anywhere
else that I have seen and is genuinely
very well done and then they are they
creating scenarios uh-oh I lost the TV
remote let's see if we can find it yeah
very very clear it's all planned out
it's it's it's which interestingly one
of the things we're talking about is
like you guys probably already know that
like all of your favorite reality shows
if you happen to watch Keeping Up with
the Kardashians you know that it's
everything that's going to take place in
an episode it's already determined
before it happens it's like okay well in
this episode you guys are gonna do this
party and this is the kind of there's
still there's a room for things to move
around a little bit but it's all pretty
much planned it's interesting they're
doing this you're gonna walk in this
room you're not gonna know where the
remote is because a producer has hidden
it but there's as much more obviously
there's as intentionally funny not
unintentionally funny like a lot of
reality television is so she's one of
those things that I found it's a blurred
genre in a very good and creative way
super innovative they're very committed
to the YouTube game like regularly
giving you videos they have a podcast
they have a schedule they're reliable in
that way
we met some of the guys at the streamys
last year mm-hmm and I was like I don't
know I again doesn't mean anything that
we don't know we didn't know exactly who
they were at the time I looked at the
stuff then was impressed with it but as
I dug in I was like yes innovative so
kind of like changing the game
establishing a new genre
playing the YouTube game very well so in
other words it's not like this
disconnected to cool
school kind of thing that can happen
when sometimes there's people who do
YouTube things some of the people that I
think will end up talking about where
you kind of feel like they're above
YouTube these guys are not too cool to
be above the YouTube game like they've
got a banner that says this is what
happens every single day on our channel
and then lastly and most importantly for
me it's just genuinely funny like
they're trying to be funny and they are
funny so okay I found one and make
jugger Nuggets does the same thing yes
that's the other one I want to talk
about this guy's been around for longer
than sugar pine 7 I'd heard this name
this guy's in Pennsylvania I believe and
he has for years we met we met him -
dude when do we meet him we were
introduced to him two years ago three
years ago just in passing at something
just feel like such a douche right now
that you pointed that out just such a
douche I mean I am it I own it if I
owned it every day mcjuggernuggets I
just remember the name from when we met
him but well this guy hadn't seen the
videos the night I went and looked he is
doing something that is so ambitious he
I was fascinated equally by this but in
a different way because he is doing
these vlogs that they seem even even
more traditional just on the surface
like lifestyle vlog is just like oh I'm
just following this guy's day but then
you pretty quickly realized that no no
no this guy's mom and dad and brother
and other people and friends and other
youtubers sometimes they're all a part
of this and it's all scripted but
they're all like incredible performers
like you can still tell that it's kind
of like I just got my dad to do this but
yeah it's I got my dad to do this in a
way that well he it's not just funny
because he can't act no it's funny
because he can well the one that I
remember is it's not his dad got mad and
there's something about it there was a
gaming console that ended up getting
taken outside and smashed by I think his
dad or
I think he has to think there was some
conflict I think he had something go
very viral it said that was yours ago
and that's the one that I watched cuz it
was you know you can sort by popular and
but I I was very intrigued but again a
lot of things that are gonna get me
excited or things that are genuinely
funny like I'm I'm giving the guy no
benefit of the doubt he's just is
actually funny and it's engaging and
it's super ambitious like oh and you
know what he in what way is that
ambitious I don't know what you mean
forty minute long vlog that is not a
subscription thing that's like 40
minutes it gets multiple okay Matt a web
multiple locations and it's all shot
through the lens of the camera and him
lifestyle as if he was vlogging but
there's there's all these situations and
all these scenes that get set up he's
actually up first for a streaming as
well I think well that's encouraging
potentially for best comedy or you may
be in a category that we're in anyway
highly recommend it
he's got the older series that you can
get into and then again it's just it's
just this guy who made this decision to
be like I'm not gonna go to LA and try
to do this traditional thing maybe you
did I don't know I'm gonna be in
Pennsylvania and I'm going to do
something that he's kind of living in
the constraints of low-budget video but
pushing it in this really innovative
original way that's actually funny an
emphasis on story yes comedy yes yes and
pulling it off gently with just
relatives and friends and one camera yes
what are you gonna do about it I am
tempted to there's a lot of content
sugar pine seven you kind of feel like
you can just sort of alright I can just
kind of get in I can just watch one of
these it's not too long I don't have to
be there from the beginning with a
mcjuggernuggets I kind of feel like I
have to be like alright pick the series
and start from the beginning
but it's a lot it would be lively time
probably pick the current one because I
think the except I kind of want to pick
the one that's up for the streaming well
I mean I wanna for for one time my life
experience the excitement of waiting for
someone to release a video that get
continues a story I've never done that
on YouTube and if you're telling me he
can do that then I my interest is piqued
and I think the one that's up for a
Streamy there's like it's like a murder
mystery because he like the first for
the guy at the first person perspective
dude at the beginning of the whole thing
is is like run over by a car and it
really be as good as Ozark to you in
your limited amount of time no I don't
think so I don't think it can I don't
think that it not that that's a comedy I
don't think I'm fair comparison I don't
want tours and I don't want to get there
yet cuz that's gonna be like where we
were we land right okay okay
Oh what else do you have I've got I've
got more I can keep going through them
but I have never watched a casing nice
tap video ever
[Applause]
like I met the guy I liked him I heard
his story I was intrigued I've always
respected him but I treated him like
every other person on YouTube which is
like okay i'm i i'm gonna watch the
thumbnails like i don't have time to
watch the videos i'm gonna watch the
thumbnails and then they started making
the thumbnails where it would like start
to tick through different images in the
video so if you watch the video better
and you know okay i I started to
understand a little bit I thought I did
but I say you know what I'm just gonna
sit down i'ma watch a couple of his
videos and it's an interesting thing
because I'm a I'm a huge fan of his now
it's just so easy because he's he's
genuine he's creative he's smart he's um
not much of an emphasis on comedy it's
so weird for me to like telling you
about a Casey Neistat video I'm the only
one who hasn't watched one and I
definitely think I mean like I
appreciated the variety and from video
to video but the just the creativity
quotient is so high that it's so
inspiring to me as from an artistic
level and it's there's a its current
like he's talking about things that are
happening like this video went viral I
was gonna you know this guy on the
subway shaving I was going to retweet
and he tells a great story
he's masterful in the way that he
presents things and then he makes you
think he's like this is I didn't retweet
this to get it to get a laugh and then I
found out the follow-up story about this
guy and he's talking about it and he's
that's just that's just one that I
watched you know he's running and he
doesn't like the rain he's talking about
what's the best what watch how super
exciting you know what's the I mean even
something like that it's like very
engaging but here's the thing that
happened to me I go in
to work mode I'm like man this inspires
me this this immediately impacts how I
approach what we create and that's why I
have not and do not watch YouTube videos
because I'll either waste my time with
stuff that I it's not for me or I'll
find something that engages me
creatively and I just can't divorce it
from the impact on my job you know what
we're gonna create and it you know it's
like I've never watched a try guys video
never sure strange because I don't feel
like I can I just can't handle I mean
Sturgill Simpson's said that he does not
did not listen to Jason Isabel's album
and I'm not trying and I lated to that
I'm well you okay what's your problem
this is I'm but he said specifically why
I didn't do it he didn't want to be
influenced by it exactly and the
influence it has on me is that it it
stresses you it stresses me out but it
and it also makes me think because with
the moment personality profile I'm like
there's always a better way to do what
I'm doing and if I don't change it's
gonna this is all gonna slip away so
anything on YouTube that's working to me
and I felt it I felt it well it was
inside of me even watching a Casey
Neistat video or the 30 minutes that I
watched him and I just felt like I
couldn't put enough of that aside to
enjoy it as a viewer
well I'm but okay I actually feel like
he's different enough but in but also
inspiring enough that there's just the
right amount of overlap that I could see
me incorporating his videos into my
daily or weekly routine
okay well because I just became a better
person by watching I became more
inspired and that that certainly
counteracted any level of anxiety that
welled up within me because I've got
problems so I mean I had actually
watched quite a few Casey Neistat videos
and I've always thought he was
masterful at what he does I usually wait
until he's talking about something that
I'm interested in as opposed to
following it on a regular basis but to
speak to what watching these folks
especially as we get into the sugar pine
seven the majora it's the casein I stats
and I'm we're gonna keep going what it
does for me is it does make me anxious
it doesn't make me stressed out but but
mostly for me it makes me frustrated I
mean the thing that I deal with mostly
is frustration like a creative block not
from lack of knowing what we want to do
but from feeling a little bit trapped to
be perfectly honest so so to expound on
that so with what we do a good mythical
morning there's a few things about it
right one is it's not really our
creativity on display
it's our personalities on display right
if anything the creativity is coming
from the people who make the graphics or
the or you know the specific formulation
of the episode which is something that
we're kind of overseeing as opposed to
formulating ourselves and so we created
this place where we could just be
ourselves and make each other laugh and
people are coming in and enjoying kind
of our personalities and the jokes that
we make and that kind of thing but from
a purely creative standpoint crafting
something creating an experience where
you're thinking about every element of
it you're thinking about the music and
you're thinking about the script you're
thinking about the plan and then how
that plan comes to fruition that's
something that we have sort of we
funneled a bunch of that into buddy
system it was frustrating that a lot of
people weren't able to see buddy system
because we feel like especially with the
second season a buddy system
it was just like pure rhett and Link
creativity being just poured out you
know and I think it meets the criteria
of your tweet by the way it does it does
and I recommend it but when I see these
guys innovating and doing things that
are artful in a way I'm like man
ah I want to do more of that now we'll
say that we're constantly working on a
lot of things besides GMM that are
they're all designed to give us that
opportunity to create that kind of
experience it's just the avenues that
we're exploring things happen slowly
nothing's a sure thing and that kind of
thing but that's the main thing we have
what we've chosen to do is to try to
make those things happen in a more
traditional sense being financed in a
more traditional way as opposed to
saying screw traditional methods of
making it in Hollywood and just make
stuff freely and independently on
YouTube mostly because you really can't
do both things that we're doing we kind
of would have to make a choice we have
to make a choice so we're gonna go back
and do what we used to do with music
videos and sketches or we gonna keep
doing GMM it's just with the way that
things work and there's only two of us
you kind of have to make a choice and GM
is not going away anytime soon
that's just that's that's the anxiety
that is created in me the creative
frustration that happens when I start
watching things that are creatively
inspiring but you could but you don't
find yourself not watching for that
reason no no no I don't know I choose to
watch to be frustrated but I actually
but I actually feel like I could watch
like I feel like I could I could watch
DeFranco show because it would I would
be more informed and it would help me
engage with the the topics that he
covers actually just as a side note I've
never watched a complete Philip DeFranco
video I probably watch Phil I I just
have to probably watch him more than any
other youtuber there have been different
focal points with individual stories but
it's all been one main story and that is
the story of youtuber burnout because
he's constantly talking about something
be the value don't know if I finish the
video but I go to the section where he
talks about the thing that I'm
interested in and I can see if I'm given
his take on it in that especially from a
from a YouTube community standpoint I
think the you know I've always felt
guilty eh
watching fellow youtubers but also not
being an active part of the community
and it you know I actually got a charge
last week out of watching videos about
youtuber burnout and talking about that
and I got it I was like wow I actually I
can see that I might start to carve out
a place for YouTube as a viewer in my
life because of the community aspect and
I started I knew that on paper but I
started to understand it because I felt
passionately about what they were saying
and their perspectives and it helped me
for my own perspective
so I'm actually open to that and that's
something that we didn't dive into too
much here so I'm not saying DeFranco is
my only place for for that or in the
stuff that Shane's doing which we
haven't talked about I want to talk
about shameless I'm saving that is it
has a lot of overlap with the community
but then engaging in terms of like the
way the creative way that he's treating
it yeah but I I when i watch the Casey
Neistat videos and I was just able to
check my ego I think it's I I think I
would like to have a relationship with
him as a viewer oh well yeah I mean I
think I have his phone number so no I'm
not as not as a not a professional
relationship a viewing relationship okay
I'll talk to him about that
yeah I can definitely see that you know
that I could oh I could watch every
single video he puts out well let's talk
about I have to carve out I don't know
when I would do that exactly in my life
but you have to put in your calendar but
that that's yeah I gotta put it on my
calendar let's talk about what we're
calling the candy category
it's not about candy but it is something
that we could not categorize but that we
both loved and wanted more of bill Wirtz
still a piece of garbage now we knew
about Bill warts from several years ago
when your biscuits won best podcast it
though he was the
webbie's of the shorties it was in New
York it was the shorties and I think was
a shortage because you had to give a
really short speech dj khaled was
backstage and ACK a lead ear biscuits
one bed best podcast it'd be radio lab
and our acceptance speech was about how
our podcast is not better than radio lab
and radio lab should've won and then Al
Roker got up and was like that's the
weirdest acceptance speech I've ever
seen but that night we'll bill Wirtz won
something and then they played that I'm
still a piece of garbage and we were
both like who is this guy he also said
something really funny when he got up
there but so I've enjoyed his stuff but
then dug in again more people coming
there's more farming and more people to
make more things for more people and now
there's business money writing laws
power
[Music]
it's surreal musical jingles with
surreal visuals to accompany them with a
certain splendid sound to his his music
sensibilities he's got this song it's a
recent song about Mount st. Helens and
and I will drop I mean this fills the
slot that bad lip reading is in so this
joins bad lip reading that I will drop
everything and watch he's got a new
video bad lip reading and we're late to
this game but I will drop everything and
watch his latest of course and you know
I went on Spotify and all of his songs
are on there and I'm like I'm like
driving down the road listen to him so
bill words and who's the other girl I
ibly great and so sort of bill works if
bill were to take a dark turn is Jack's
Tauber so still music and similar
strangers with trippy trippy stuff very
very comedic he I think Jack probably
inserts himself a little bit more
personally into the videos like well I
mean Bill does that too yeah but it's
like a combination of music videos which
are great and animated videos that are
just creepy and weird but also
incredibly funny depending on what mood
you're in and it's much more at least I
hope I'm not wrong and saying this it
seems to be much more regularly updated
than bill works like he's much more
regular it seems like he was doing like
a weekly a weekly video it's not just
his isn't just music but it's also like
surreal sketches yeah the very animated
stuff yeah pinpointed Jack Stauber I
think he's I think he's in well they're
the one that I recommend watching this
animated one called Pete PBJ which is
about peanut butter and jelly daddy I
said I only wanted jelly on the sand
and it's just so funny I mean it's so
specifically funny I mean you have to
have a very specific sense of humor to
like it but I loved it
I mean the candy stuff is just bite-size
what whenever it hits your subscription
box you hear about it you stop
everything to watch it I won't even show
that to all my friends got a head my
wife and they would like it so I I would
watch that with my wife but it's a it's
a 30-second video yeah it's some case
it's a totally but it's just a you're
standing in line somewhere you know
right I can't have more of that in my
life
okay well instead of just going on
reddit all the time do you have anything
else from the list that you want talk
about because I wanted to save Shane for
last and I have some strong thing I want
to save for last that can be next to us
is us like I I'm curious us did would if
you weren't us would you watch good
mythical morning so let's talk about you
chain and then let's talk about that to
shut it down because I think that was I
think we brought up that question in
part one okay so would we watch good
mythical morning if we weren't in it
alright we will answer that question
before we're done so I've talked about
things that are innovative and
mesmerizing and things that I can see
myself going and committing to and you
talked about Shane in part one a good
amount but though but the thing that I
will say again and I don't know how many
parts were into the Jake Paul series by
the time that you listen to this and I
will say that I haven't even watched
part one yet because I'm saving it
here's why because I know that I can sit
down in my place in my bed with my wife
before I go to bed and say hey I want
you to watch this series with me and it
is the one thing that I can without
reservation be like she's gonna be into
this is what Shane has done with his
approach to documentary on YouTube again
I just it kind of started the
conversation of like what else is there
and I'd say for the most part we pretty
much found what we expected we found
really niche stuff we found some people
doing some really innovative
things just based on the parameters of
the platform we found some really funny
people we found some people doing basic
basically just replicating what you
could find on television but Shane is
doing something that I think is
different for a reason because it is it
is something you could find in terms of
the format there's compelling
documentaries it's become a huge part of
our culture entertainment culture but
he's the only one doing it about YouTube
in the way that is actually interesting
to people who are part of the community
and has the access and the trust that
you need to be able to have the
conversations that I know that he had
with Jake Paul I basically reached out
to him and I was like hey if we do a
series together I want to really be
honest about it and investigate and do
it in such a timely fashion so to be a
part of the community but to highlight
the community in a way that a
professional documentarian would do
traditionally that's something that
doesn't exist he's changed the game I've
already said it but that's the one thing
I can confidently say that I've had to
hold myself back from watching part one
it's 40 minutes long he's got eight
parts I've had to hold myself back from
watching it because I was like I gotta
watch all this other stuff and this is
the one thing I'm gonna save and be like
Jesse let's sit down and let's watch
this together
so I still think that after this whole
thing I'm back to Shane is doing the
most compelling thing on YouTube right
now there it is
I said it again I already said it I said
it again I and I know that I'll like it
when I watch it and again I will you
watch it yeah I just I've got it I've
got some more internal work to do just
to make sure that I don't work I just
enjoy it like it has nothing to do with
his work it just has to do with me like
I gotta get I gotta stop working or
seeing how does this impact what we do
you know I wish yeah it's like just
right now here's what I think here's my
advice so yeah I can do that when you
fill
compelled when you feel like you
shouldn't watch those things just watch
them and just take some notes so you
just get the you process whatever it is
that you feel like you want to learn and
apply to what we do just take some notes
and again it'll just it's a no it's a no
way competition that I'm pretty clear
about that right it's not about
competition and am I better or we
falling behind it just makes you feel
like we have changes it's not a
comparison thing it's a I actually do
get inspired and then I feel hamstrung
with you know how do I have a place
where I can apply and that's a funny
thing to say when like we could make
anything we want technically technically
practically right it seems it seems like
we could but practically the answer is
no okay would you watch us would I watch
us it's it's it's almost an impossible
question okay cuz I know myself yes and
no okay let me say let me say then no
part I'll start with the no I'll start
with a negative well here's the I think
we're looking I won't I know I'm just
I'm not trying to cut you off I'm just
go ahead the no part you don't want you
to give me the answer and then I just
have to say yeah I agree
okay well cuz I don't know what I think
I don't if you know what you think I
have to figure it out by talking that's
why I cut you off okay I don't think
we're gonna think the same thing though
I don't know what I think well then just
let me talk and then think and talk with
a second because then I'll just agree
with you know you want the reason I
would not watch us is because I don't
watch anything on a daily basis because
the structure that we created which is
actually the reason for the success of
the show in many ways is the fact that
we created a 10 to 15 minute experience
and if you add more you're getting up to
20 minutes every single day that you can
carve out and you know what's gonna
happen at a certain time right my
schedule does not allow currently for
that window to beef there is no window
there is no like I don't watch anything
the only thing that I do on a regular
basis is during my drive into work I
will listen to a podcast or a book on
tape audible and that's the window and
our show doesn't it doesn't fit we don't
decide to do this we have a podcast but
we're making it right now but GMM is not
that so I don't have a place for a daily
video so no I would not watch our show
as it is intended to be watched every
day
that's my no part I have a yes part that
I would watch and I think I think that
everything you said is the reason why I
that would be a yes for me because I
knew I know I could count on it I can
make it a part of my daily routine like
the way that thankfully so many people
have and so I could actually again you
know I was joking about you're joking
about the calendar but yeah it's because
I'm so schedule oriented like okay I
could have a relationship with this show
because I can count on it and you know
if it if it gives me something that I
need it's just like you know when when
my grandparents watch you know they
watch Pat Sajak every night you know
it's like all right that's what we're
after dinner that's what we do sit down
and watch the wheel spin mm-hmm you know
and I think a lot of people do that with
our show they watch it after dinner with
breakfast whatever we just as a family
we don't have those things that we watch
we listen to music while we eat dinner
that's what we just made some different
choices that don't allow for good
mythical morning on a daily basis or
something like it and I think the other
the other thing we were getting at is
that we're so compelled by story that's
a brilliant thing that Shane did is that
he you know and I'm making a murder
count away he draws you in in multiple
parts series and then you it fits a
certain certain time slot that you want
to fill with story and intrigue and in
that case reality and also learning a
about a fascinating person or situation
so as far as the content of our show I
mean there's not there's not that much
story you know a lot of I think a lot of
people we put we put a lot of that in
this podcast now because it was part of
good mythical morning early
and I think it it's it's a it's a big
part of this show
yeah right but that being said since
it's not a big part of good mythical
morning anymore
I I don't know I don't know if I would
watch because it's missing that this the
story which could be a reality story
that has stakes or you know with other
other people on YouTube that I'm trying
yeah you know that I'm open to or it
could be script it or it obviously likes
a scripted story so I don't know if cuz
that I think that would be the next
thing because like would I be
entertained by those guys I I mean I
guess well that was so that's the yes
board I want to say and this is this is
some weird egotistical thing to say but
there I can get to a place and I do this
sometimes when I'm watching back one of
our videos now usually my motivation to
go to one of our videos is to see what
people are thinking about it if I do
that within the YouTube studio app I
don't have to watch the video I can just
see the comments but everyone well I'll
do that while I'm all on the internet
and I go to the video and it just starts
playing work the kids are watching the
video when I get home I'll watch an
episode I find myself watching or if
there was something particular about
that episode that I wanted to see how I
came across some new watch it back but
the majority of what we make on GMM we
don't watch back
so but I can put myself in the shoes of
a person who is not us just watching us
and there are many times when I'm
sitting there watching and I and I think
to myself
those guys are funny I think for me it's
I like those guys III don't yeah I like
those I'm saying it like I'm like just
like I said about you'll notice that all
the people that I that I connected with
I said genuinely funny and I am I am I
will say with a total egotistical pride
I think I'm genuinely funny you know I
think we're both genuinely funny I think
the comedy that we've created is
genuinely funny otherwise I would be I
would feel sick about what we're doing
yeah that would be what I'm saying yeah
so but that's that's one of the reasons
we keep doing it I think we're actually
creating a genuinely funny engaging
thing that just because it's if it's a
format that I couldn't practically fit
into my life right now doesn't mean that
I can't as a third party look at it and
be like I see I get it I understand why
you'd want to sit down and watch those
guys got it move on to the next thing
that's how I would evaluate us
pridefully but unashamedly at the same
time what have we learned man I don't
know what it is about this this whole
exercise it was tiring so exactly like
exhausted yeah let's go work some more
though that's what we're gonna do yeah
yeah I I think that the casein ice that
thing for me I I do acknowledge that it
that it's an odd thing to say but I
think it I think it opens a door for me
to say okay there may be room for
personality-driven
high creativity quotient content in my
life on a weekly basis that I could
follow him and other people like him
that I could find and have a viewing
relationship an ongoing viewing
relationship with with with those people
I think that's a totally different
approach and you know and then what out
what I thought I was looking for which
was appointment viewing would you know
to when I would normally watch a
documentary or like a scripted thing
yeah I think the conclusion for me is I
don't see my viewing habits changing
drastically because of this exercise I
think that I am going to primarily
continue to enjoy scripted and again to
clarify when I say scripted I mean there
was a script written for
oh so story-based scripted television
and movies there's gonna be my primary
source of entertainment and then I'm
going to boo popcorn enjoyment of
certain shorter things on YouTube but
the thing I'm adding I've already talked
about Shane I think you could fill that
spot but I think that some of the people
that I mentioned who are doing
innovative things are I feel like I'm on
the verge of like doing a deeper dive if
I can find the time and I don't think I
would regret any of that so I think I
have been changed somewhat but I want to
do this again I I feel like this is an
exercise that we have to do at least
annually why yeah and I I do feel like
in the when definitely before good
mythical morning when we didn't have a
format that we like put our head down
and we could just focus on I I did watch
a lot of YouTube videos in the name of
research and impacting like I was a
student of everything that was working
on YouTube to impact what we were going
to do next like probably a lot more than
you and I think that's why I have such a
hard time turning that off um so but I
also feel like I can I can be engaged
and inspired and it can't affect our
work and that's also a good thing as
long as I put it in its place but I've
turned it off entirely for a few years
and I've missed out so I think that's
another aspect of I can crack that door
back open thank you for helping us do
that with all of your suggestions and
for hanging with us hopefully you're not
exhausted having listened to us I just
like I should actually feel bad at the
end of a podcast in my head I'm
exhausted but um well I'm it's just the
culmination of this exercise and it was
what we did what we didn't say was like
what does this mean for YouTube and
people like us because I was hoping that
we'd come back and there'd be like more
stuff and be like there's hope for
people who you YouTube does it doesn't
work for them and it's gonna start
working for them and they're gonna
they're gonna come in dry think that I
think that I think first of all I think
YouTube premium is true
to fill that void and maybe they will
but I think that ultimately people like
me and you were just gonna get old and
die well that's that's a safe bet
yeah and a great ending yeah alright
guys we'll speak at you next week
but trust we're gonna be getting older
and closer to dying
hashtag ear biscuits
[Music]